This episode of DNews is brought to you by
Squarespace.
Surfers think catching a gnarly wave is radical?
Thanks to some science we can ride air currents
at almost the speed of sound with 200 ton
surfboards in the sky.
How’s that for radical?
Hey silver surfers, Julian here for DNews.
British airways flight 114 recently made a
transatlantic crossing almost an hour quicker
than usual, and was clocking ground speeds
of 745 miles per hour, or nearly 1,200 kph.
It’s been making news because that is a
frankly ludicrous speed, considering the speed
of sound at that altitude is somewhere around
1100 kph.
But when you take into account the airspeed,
that is the speed the airplane is traveling
through the air around it, instead of the
groundspeed it didn’t actually break the
sound barrier, which is a good thing because
the Boeing 777 really wasn’t designed for
that.
Fortunately for everyone stuck in coach, the
aircraft was riding a particularly ferocious
jet stream that was at times over 320 kilometers
per hour.
But why do we have jet streams?
First of all jet streams are not unique to
earth.
We’ve observed them on Jupiter and Saturn.
Here on Earth jet streams form in the troposphere,
the lowest atmospheric level, and there can
be many that swirl and flow and join and split.
Most of them head from west to east, so if
you’ve flown from North America to Europe,
you’ve probably noticed your flight is shorter
in that direction.
The one you and flight 114 cruised on is the
northern hemisphere’s polar jet stream.
The polar jet streams are from 7 to 12 kilometer
up, but each hemisphere also has weaker subtropical
jet streams that are 10 to 16 kilometers up.
Jet streams form at boundary layers between
warm air and cold air.
The higher pressure cold air pushes into the
low pressure area, and in the winter the pressure
differences are greater so you get stronger
winds.
But the wind doesn’t just move in a straight
line from pole to tropics because of the coriolis
effect.
Basically the planet spinning underneath the
moving air deflects it east.
Higher in the troposphere there’s less friction
so these winds can go unbroken for thousands
of miles and voila, jet steam.
Throw in modern air travel and if you’re
lucky you can get where you want to go at
almost the speed of sound.
Switching gears for a second, we'd like to
thank Squarespace for this episode of DNews.
Squarespace recently launched the latest version
of their platform, Squarespace Seven, which
has a completely redesigned interface, integrations
with Getty Images and Google Apps, new templates,
and an incredible feature called Cover Pages.
Try the new Squarespace, at Squarespace.com/dnews,
and enter offer code DNews at checkout to
get 10% off.
Squarespace.
Start Here.
Go Anywhere.
If you don’t think I’ve gone basic enough
to explain why there are jet streams, Trace
explains air itself here.
Also, you were probably one of those kids
who kept asking why all the time, huh?
I like it, keep it up.
So planning a world trip, would you head westerly
to ride the current, or east to west to feel
like a time traveler?
Tough call, but me, I like cruising into the
sunset for hours.
Let us know in the comments and I’ll see
you next time on DNews.